For 146 years, the Barnum and Bailey Circus
was known for being the greatest show on earth.
None of it would have been possible if it
were not for an ambitious entrepreneur named
PT Barnum. While his life and career were
sometimes the source of controversy, he truly
was a brilliant businessman, and many of his
ideas forever changed the entertainment industry
as we know it today.
Early Life
Phineas Taylor Barnum was born in 1810 in
Bethel, Connecticut. His parents, Philo Barnum
and Irene Taylor were farmers who rented out
rooms in their home for extra income. His
grandfather was a well-respected judge in
the town. On the day of his baptism, PT Barnum
inherited a 4.7-acre piece of land from his
grandfather called “Ivy Island”. His parents
were poor, but as a child, he grew up believing
that he was the richest kid in town, because
he thought that he inherited a private island
somewhere that he could build a house on some
day. When he was 10 years old, his parents
finally took him on a trip to visit Ivy Island,
where he discovered that it was virtually
worthless. The island was muddy land in the
middle of a swamp, and it was filled with
poisonous snakes, ticks, and poison ivy. He
never did anything with the land. Today, it
now part of a nature reserve called the Bethel
Land Trust.
This was clearly disappointing, and it left
him yearning for a reality where he truly
would be rich enough to buy a private island
some day. But he wasn’t interested in the
traditional ways of making money. By his own
admission, he had the reputation of being
“the laziest boy in town”, because he
hated doing farm work and manual labor. Instead
of forcing Phineas into caring for the family
farm, his father helped get him a job as a
clerk in the town grocery store. This was
a perfect fit, and Phineas grew to love the
idea of running his own business. When he
was only 15 years old, his father died, and
he was now the man of the family. This motivated
him even more to make as much money as he
possibly could. He was possessed by the entrepreneurial
spirit, and he began trying different business
ventures right away.
His most successful business as a teenager
was running a lottery. While working in the
grocery store, he had an endless supply of
glass bottles and tin advertising trays that
he was expected to throw away. He knew that
these items would be useful in people’s
homes, and he wanted to recycle them in some
way. But people were not interested in buying
them second-hand. He started selling tickets
for a lottery, instead. He promised that half
of the tickets sold would be guaranteed to
win something. There were a few big cash prizes,
and consolation prizes were those items he
got for free. He sold 1,000 tickets in just
the first week, and he continued to run the
lottery over and over again.
When he was just 16 years old, he used all
of the money he earned from these lotteries
to move to Brooklyn, New York to open his
own grocery store. Unfortunately, he caught
smallpox, and had to move back to Connecticut
so his mother could help nurse him back to
health. After recovering from his illness,
he knew he needed to try again. When he was
18, he opened up a confectionary shop in his
home town that sold fruit and candy. He was
able to run more lotteries in his own store.
He married his first wife, Charity Hallett,
when he was 19 years old, and she was 21.
They would eventually go on to have four daughters
together. While he was never overly romantic,
he did write that his wife was a “treasure”,
and that “Without Charity, I am nothing.”
When he was 21, he wrote several passionate
articles about politics and sent them in to
the local newspaper, but they were all rejected.
He decided that if no one was going to publish
his work, he would self-publish his own paper,
called The Herald Freedom. He had enough money
to buy his own printing press, and handed
out the newspapers in town. In one of his
articles, he exposed the corrupt leaders of
the town’s local church. The men sued him
for libel, since he had no proof to back up
his claims in court. He ended up paying a
$100 fine and spent 60 days in jail. When
he was released, he became a local hero, and
a leader of the liberal movement. Everyone
loved him in Bridgeport, but he decided that
he achieved all he could possibly do in Connecticut.
He wanted to move to New York City, where
he knew he would have so many more opportunities
to earn his fortune.
The First Taste Of Show Business
PT and Charity Barnum bought a boarding house
in New York City so they could earn some income
by renting out their extra rooms, just like
his parents had done back in Connecticut.
He used his knowledge from working in retail
to have partial ownership of a grocery store
without having to do any of the work, and
continued to run his weekly lotteries. He
set himself up in a pretty great financial
situation, and he was still in his early 20’s.
His family’s basic needs of food and housing
were met, but his sights were on bigger and
better ways to make as much money as he possibly
could.
When he was 25 years old, he met a man who
told him about Joice Heth, who was an elderly
African American slave woman. She claimed
to be George Washington’s nanny, and would
go on and on with her stories of their time
together. If this was true, it would have
made her 161 years old. Barnum was able to
pay her owner $1,000 in order to put her on
display. She looked so incredibly old, that
people actually believed that she may have
truly been 161. People came from all over
New York City to see her. She died after only
one year of touring. There was a public autopsy
that revealed she was only about 80 years
old, but people were not angry about the deception.
While it was a “humbug”, people still
enjoyed the spectacle. This gave PT Barnum
a preview of the showman experience. If he
could find even more fantastic and interesting
attractions, he didn’t have to do any of
the hard manual labor he dreaded so much.
He could just hire talented people to perform,
and collect the money from ticket sales.
PT Barnum tried to sell tickets to acts with
performers who specialized in juggling and
plate spinning, but most of those shows did
not do well, because people had seen these
acts before. He realized that he had gotten
very lucky with having Joice Heth as his very
first attraction. People really wanted to
pay for something they had never seen, but
he had a difficult time figuring out what
to look for without having any experience
in the entertainment industry. When he was
26, he temporarily left behind his wife and
children to join a traveling circus in order
to educate himself on everything he needed
to know about show business.
The owner of the circus was a man named Aaron
Turner, and Barnum told him that he was eager
to learn more about the business. Turner decided
to give him a first-hand experience with getting
a crowd’s attention. The day before their
opening show, Turner pointed at PT Barnum
when he was standing in front of a crowd,
claiming that Barnum was Reverend Ephraim
Avery, who was well-known in the newspapers
for being acquitted of murder. Everyone knew
that Avery was truly guilty, and they were
all talking about him. Not many people knew
what he actually looked like, but they all
passionately hated this man.
Of course, people believed Turner’s claim,
and they began chasing after Barnum, who started
running away. The angry mob got bigger and
bigger, and they were ready to take justice
into their own hands by lynching the “murderer”.
At the last moment, Aaron Turner shouted that
they were circus performers, and he did it
as a practical joke. Even though this could
have been seen as “bad publicity”, it
worked. Everyone in the town was talking about
the angry mob, and wanted to know what kind
of crazy men would pull such dangerous jokes
on each other. They bought tickets to the
show the next day.
After six months with the circus, Barnum started
his own small troupe of traveling performers
called, “Barnum's Grand Scientific and Musical
Theater”. He even bought a steam boat to
give tours and musical performances along
the rivers in the south. But after about a
year of living on the road, he became very
homesick. He missed his wife and kids, and
he wanted stability. He returned to New York,
hoping to find a way to display curiosities
and performances without traveling from place
to place.
The American Museum
In 1841, Barnum purchased the Scudder’s
American Museum and transformed it to be a
much more appealing place to visit. He added
flags to the outside, and created an elaborate
rooftop garden, where a hot air balloon gave
people rides on a daily basis. Inside, he
had a menagerie of exotic animals, magicians,
and miniaturized recreations of famous battles.
PT Barnum was a genius when it came to getting
more people to come to his attractions. When
the American Museum first opened, he wasn’t
selling as many tickets as he had hoped. So,
he found an unemployed man, and paid him to
run through a cycle of various movements.
He would pick up a brick on the street, carry
it to the door, show his ticket to the museum,
and walk inside. Then, he would walk back
out again, place the brick down, and pick
up another. He continued to do this every
single day, to the point where people noticed
this ritual on their way to and from work.
Some would even stop to watch this man, and
they asked what he was doing. It was enough
to get people curious enough to buy a ticket
for themselves, so they could see inside.
As time went on, Barnum used the money he
made from ticket sales to improve the quality
of his displays. He added one of his most
famous hoaxes, The Fiji Mermaid. He claimed
that it was the body of a mermaid that had
been caught off the coast of Fiji, but it
was really the skeleton of a monkey sewn onto
a fishtail. One of his most popular live exhibits
was known as the “Freak Show”. While some
people disapprove of the fact that he exploited
people with physical abnormalities like bearded
ladies and people with extra limbs, he was
giving many of these people work when they
would have otherwise never found a job out
in the real world. He also paid his employees
very well, and they were all treated like
members of the family. Every single one of
the members of the so-called Freak Shows became
incredibly rich, and all they had to do was
stand on display. Some of them chose to retire
after just a few years of working, and they
went on to get married and have normal lives.
When Barnum was 33 years old, he had been
running his American Museum for a few years,
and had found some success. But he was always
looking out for the next big thing. He met
Charles Stratton, who was one of his distant
cousins. Charles was only 4 years old when
they met. He was a proportionate dwarf, standing
only 25 inches tall. He would stay the size
of a baby for the rest of his life. Charles’
father was a carpenter, so their family did
not have a lot of money. They were afraid
for their son’s future. Not many dwarves
could find work outside of the entertainment
industry, and they were never the star of
the show. They were always on the sidelines,
used as the butt of a joke. PT Barnum agreed
to be his cousin’s manager, and he spent
months teaching him how to sing, dance, and
act. He was not sure how well the audiences
would enjoy the show, so at first, he paid
the boy’s parents $3 a week, which is the
modern-day equivalent of $70. His parents
agreed, and they were happy that their young
son could earn any money at all.
PT Barnum’s strategy with Charles’ performance
was to make him the polar opposite of what
people expected from a dwarf. He gave the
boy the stage name of “Tom Thumb”, after
the well-loved English fairy tale. He also
claimed that he was already 10 years old instead
of 5, which made his small stature even more
incredible. Thankfully, Charles was very smart
child, and he picked up on how to talk with
the a bigger vocabulary. Barnum advertised
Tom Thumb as a “tiny gentleman”, dressing
him in tailor-made suits. He was able to memorize
complicated lines, and performed roles of
dignified figures in history, like Napoleon
Bonaparte. It worked.
He traveled all over the United States and
Europe, becoming one of the world’s first
international celebrities. Even Queen Victoria
was a fan of little Tom Thumb. As time went
on, PT Barnum hired other proportionate dwarves
to join his American Museum. This is where
Charles Stratton met his future wife, Lavinia
Warren. Barnum threw them a wedding ceremony
that became front-page news. President Abraham
Lincoln was also a huge fan, and threw them
a honeymoon party at the White House. Stratton
made so much money through performing, he
could have retired at a very young age. But
he genuinely enjoyed it so much, he continued
until he died at 45 years old.
The museum became so popular, that people
would buy one ticket and stay there all day,
even if they got to the end of the tour. It
would get so crowded, that Barnum had to figure
out a way to trick people into leaving. He
put up a sign that said, “This way to the
Egress”. People assumed that it was another
attraction, but really, “egress” is just
a fancy word for “exit”. Once they left
the building, they could no longer open the
door, and if they wanted to come back inside,
they needed to stand in line and buy another
ticket.
Iranistan, and The Music Business
After having so much success with his American
Museum, Barnum was able to build a massive
palace in Connecticut for his family to live.
He called the home Iranistan, because of its
middle-eastern inspiration. He modeled the
building after the Brighton Royal Pavilion
in England, which was the summer home of George,
Prince of Wales. He was able to host events
and bring in famous guest from around the
world, like the author Mark Twain. He used
the large halls for musical performances.
He believed that by building such a huge castle,
famous musicians would be more likely to perform
at his venues. It worked.
In 1850, PT Barnum tried his luck at finding
musical talent from overseas. He convinced
a Swedish opera singer named Jenny Lind to
come to New York to perform. According to
his autobiography, Jenny Lind only agreed
to travel to the United States because she
saw the engraving of Iranistan on the invitation
letter, and she wanted to visit this intriguing
palace. He had never heard her sing, but he
learned of her reputation when visiting Europe.
Barnum was taking a huge risk by hiring Jenny
Lind, especially since he had no experience
in the music industry. He even paid her in
advance to travel to The United States. But
Barnum used his marketing genius to hype up
her arrival so much, Americans believed she
was one of the greatest singers in the world,
and that they would be foolish to miss her
limited-time performance. He created posters
that dubbed her “The Swedish Nightingale”.
Her first performance was held in the Castle
Garden, and tickets were sold out.
The shows were so popular, Jenny Lind performed
with Barnum 93 times over the course of five
months. This new-found fame gave her enough
momentum to hire a new manager and go on a
world tour. Barnum was taking a cut of the
ticket sales, of course. Jenny Lind earned
$350,000 while she was working with Barnum
for those few months, and she went on to make
more during her tour. Barnum received $500,000,
which is the modern-day equivalent of nearly
$15 million.
Tragically, in 1857, men who were hired to
do repairs on Iranistan while Barnum was away
in New York left a pipe burning when they
left for the day, and it caused a fire that
destroyed everything. His insurance policy
only paid out $28,000, even though it cost
over $150,000 to build the mansion. And then,
in 1865, The American Museum burned down,
as well. He rebuilt the museum, but after
only being open a couple years, it burned
down a second time. Barnum said that the fires
“burned to the ground all of his life’s
accomplishments”.
The Barnum and Bailey Circus
At 60 years old, PT Barnum’s life was a
roller coaster of success and failure. He
was at an age where most men would decide
to cut their losses and retire. But one of
the many things that made PT Barnum such a
success was that he didn’t let his failures
stop him from moving forward. His children
were all grown up, and his wife Charity had
passed away. He decided that it was the right
time in his life to start a traveling circus.
He was the very first circus owner to buy
his own train to move the performers and equipment
from place to place. He paid his workers well,
and he made sure to use bright, colorful,
elaborate tents and equipment to attract crowds.
His first traveling show was called “P.
T. Barnum's Grand Traveling Museum, Menagerie,
Caravan & Hippodrome.” This had many of
the same attractions he once had in his American
Museum, only on a grander scale. People outside
of New York City were able to see his freak
show, animal menageries, and impressive acrobatic
talent that he had collected over the years
of networking and making friends in show business.
In 1881, when he was 71 years old, he joined
up with another circus owned by James Bailey,
and their combined acts became the famous
Barnum & Bailey Greatest Show On Earth. They
were the first “three ring circus”- meaning
that they would have three different acts
going on at the same time. One of his biggest
attractions at the Barnum & Bailey Circus
was Jumbo the Elephant. He was one of the
most popular animals for children in London,
and kids in America felt the same way. Everyone
was mesmerized by the massive scale of this
circus, and they only continued to improve
upon the show as time went on. The Barnum
and Bailey Circus continued to tour long after
his death, only ending in 2017. It went on
for 146 years.
Later Life, and Legacy
As he grew older, fewer and fewer people criticized
PT Barnum for the tricks he played on audiences,
and more people recognized the impact he made
on the entertainment industry. He was well-respect
by just about everyone. He wrote four best-selling
books in his later years, including one called
The Art of Money-Getting. In another book,
Humbugs of the World, he was very candid about
psychics and magicians’ tricks, and he even
called out Harry Houdini. He knew all the
tricks of the trade, and wrote that he would
pay $500 to any medium who could truly convince
him that they were actually talking to the
dead. His point was that even though we know
magic and ghosts are not real, that doesn’t
mean we can’t enjoy the spectacle.
Very few people know that PT Barnum took politics
very seriously, especially in his later years.
In his autobiography, he wrote that “a man
who takes no interest in politics is unfit
to live in a land where the government rests
in the hands of the people.” In 1865, US
Congress would be voting on the amendment
of the constitution to outlaw slavery. Technically,
he had once been a slave-owner himself, with
Joice Heth. But he worked with and loved so
many African American performers over the
years. He felt so passionately about fighting
for their freedom, that he used his money
and connections to join the Republican party
as part of the Connecticut legislature. He
wanted to do everything within his power to
help end slavery in the United States, and
they succeeded. The time he spent on the Connecticut
legislature wasn’t the end of his political
career. In 1875, he became the mayor of Bridgeport,
Connecticut, and served for one year.
When he was getting older, PT Barnum paid
a reporter from the local newspaper to write
a very flattering eulogy so that he could
hear and enjoy it while he was still alive.
He died in 1891 of a stroke, at 79 years old.
He loved his job so much, he was working up
until the day he died, and his last words
were a request to look over some receipts.
Two years after his death, a statue was built
in Seaside Park in Bridgeport, Connecticut,
on land he had donated to the city.
Today, his legacy still lives on in the minds
and hearts of everyone who remembers the circus,
and his work has influenced entertainment
as we know it throughout
the world.